so you may remember on the show
yesterday i talked about the idea of
laundering lies that this is in essence
what the media is doing so i was talking
about it yesterday
in the context of jen pasaki the white
house
press secretary on brian stelter's show
you know the most ironically named show
in the history of television reliable
sources and what
stelter was asking was in effect what
could we
what could we as the media do to help
the messaging
of the presidency more what could
journalists do better and it was ideal
laundering because you would never
ask that of the people you're supposed
to be holding to account
so they just launder their lies and then
it sort of seems like news oh
the press secretary was on with stealth
right and it's on cnn it kind of seems
like news but in effect they're just
laundering a lie well
i got a perfect perfect example of it to
show you right now so before i show you
the clip
this is msnbc and they did a segment
on a washington post op-ed by the
by a guy by the name of max boot and
he's just sort of a never trump
republican which again it's just one of
these pet republicans you'll never
defend
any sort of conservative idea but they
let you go on msnbc and they treat you
like a pet and you get your cookie and
you go home
and you never actually accomplish
anything or defend any of your purported
ideas or anything like that i would say
this is sort of like bill crystal or
david from these
or the lincoln project people these are
just ineffectual
sort of nobodies nobody likes them
except the msnbc people
that use them as pets well he wrote a
piece in washington post
called too many people are
underestimating the trump
threat so here you have a guy writing a
piece
in washington post about the trump
threat now that sounds very scary
then on msnbc they analyze this very
piece that he wrote and they bring in a
journalist from the new york times her
name is mara gay
uh to analyze this trump threat
now before i show you the clip you may
remember as i said earlier mara gay just
a few weeks ago
was interviewing andrew yang uh in the
new york times and said that
me dave rubin that i regularly host
white supremacists
i tweeted at her many times asking her
for clarification on that of course she
did not respond we also gave away a
month free to anyone who signed up
uh at the reuben report community in
honor of marigay i think we used mara it
was code mara
at the time uh so i thank you for that
mara she also got the name of the show
wrong she called it the dave rubin show
we couldn't get a retraction or a
correction or anything because these
people aren't journalists they're just
human jokes
that show up on these shows but anyway
uh
she then so you have a washington post
writer who writes an op-ed
then msnbc covers that very op-ed who's
written you know it's written in effect
by an activist a democratic activist
it's then covered in msnbc and they
bring in a new york times journalist
to analyze it and you're not going to
believe it this woman was on long island
and they had american flags
video long island this weekend uh
visiting a really
dear friend and i was really disturbed i
saw you know dozens and dozens of pickup
trucks with uh you know
uh explicatives against joe biden
on the back of them uh trump flags
and some cases just dozens of american
flags
which you know is also just disturbing
because essentially the message was
clear it was
this is my country this is not your
country
i own this and so until we're ready to
have that conversation
this is going to continue i think she
means expletives not explicatives but i
don't want to be a white supremacist by
correcting anyone's english
but look i come from long island one of
the
good things i think one of the things
that actually made me who i
am the reason that perhaps you watch
this show is that long island is
actually a wonderfully
diverse place where you're outside of
new york city you know about 45 minutes
outside of new york city so it's the
suburbs
of the big city and what you got there
was so many people who were second and
third generation americans whose parents
you know grew up basically in queens and
brooklyn in tenement houses and small
apartments just like my grandparents
you know one bedroom six kids uh and
and then eventually through hard work in
the american dream they got
their families to be able to move out to
the suburbs my family is literally an
example of the american dream and
so many people whether they were irish
or italian or jewish or black or
hispanic or whatever it is
all did that on long island long
island's sort of the best example
of what america could be in a certain
sense and then have that proximity to
the big city where the the further
generations who then
then were middle class could go and
follow their dreams
and some crazy kid from long island
could try to do stand-up comedy in new
york city
for years and then eventually do
something that led to something pretty
decent
in 2021 yeah this guy um it's a
beautiful place long island
anyway her fear first off that there
were people
with trucks with with uh anti-biden
messages on the
the the trucks i suppose or the flags
first off i just don't believe that i
mean there may have been
one or two that she saw but like have
any of you anyone watching this
seen lots of trucks driving around like
can i say the f word
we don't want to get demonetized sue so
much ask a screw
old joe biden have you seen that flag
have you seen that flag no
when trump was president everywhere you
went there were pictures of trump as a
nazi and crossing out his face and
giving him a mustache and all of those
things
but but further it's really the flag
part here that's disturbing hey i think
she's just mostly making this stuff up
but
she has what i think is and i don't mean
to make this about her
it doesn't it really doesn't matter
about her and i don't even care what she
said about me
but but the idea that a new york times
journalist goes on msnbc to comment on a
washington post story
shows you how they launder the lies and
that then she gets up there and
she fears the american flag and and
don't take my word for it listen to what
she's saying when she sees the american
flag
that somehow triggers a thought in her
mind about white supremacy and then you
can sort of link it back
to what obama just said that you know
these the white people are getting
nervous and that they
i don't know they pray to the american
flag to keep what they've lost like it's
just a bunch
of of self-serving myopic
drivel that really is what it is and
in some ways mara
you're the racist you're the racist
nobody cares what color you are i wish
you well in whatever it is that you're
doing
right like that's great you work at the
new york times it's a crumbling
place of journalism and you're not a
very good journalist but like
great for you to have that job that
that's just fantastic so i don't mean to
make this about you
mara but the point is you're obsessed
with race
so it's do you think it's possible could
it be possible that people
i know this is crazy i'm going to need a
little bit of a leash here people
do you think it's possible that
somewhere in america there are some
people who are proud
of the american flag and proud of the
constitution and the bill of rights and
this wonderful country that we've had
for 250 years that have give has given
more freedom
to more people than could have ever been
imaginable do you think there are some
people that are worried that that we're
losing that
not having anything to do with race but
that we're actually
trading in equality for equity we're
erasing our own history
and demolishing the things that freed
people
in the name of your crazed social
justice and it has nothing to do with
them being
racist it has them has everything to do
with them caring about freedom and
liberty and that kind of stuff
do you think that that's possible and
and the answer i suspect and mari you're
welcome to come on the show
to tell me this yourself but i suspect
her answer would be no because
they see everything in a racialized
world
but i can tell you this when i went to
donald trump rallies and i went to a few
here in crazy lefty california
in the heart of los angeles in beverly
hills bananas beverly hills
i saw american flags everywhere i saw
trump flags i saw all sorts of stuff i
saw gay flags
and everybody was really nice
and i didn't see any racist people so i
think it's possible that the american
flag stands for something other than
race
and that you're unfortunately you're in
some sort of requiem for a dream where
you see the american flag
and it makes you think that everyone's
racist not good uh and now this is a
little bit of a cheap shot but
you know it's youtube what am i gonna do
if you don't remember who mara gaye is
well here she is uh
doing some math on msnbc with brian
williams and of course if you don't
remember brian williams he was the nbc
anchor he was once on nbc
nightly news the prime time anchor at 6
30 pm they caught him lying and his
punishment
was to have to host the show on msnbc
that's a beautiful thing
so she went on his show you may remember
this from a couple months back
but you see it as a possibility if he
wants to spend a billion bucks
beating this guy he could do it
absolutely
um somebody tweeted recently that um
actually with the money he spent he
could have given every american
a million dollars got it let's put it up
on the screen it when i
read it uh tonight on social media it
kind of all became
clear bloomberg spent 500 million on ads
u.s population 327
million uh don't tell us if you're ahead
of us on the math he could have given
each american
one million dollars and have had lunch
money left over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's an incredible way
of putting it it's true it's disturbing
it does
it does suggest you know what we're
talking about here which is
there's too much money in politics
i'm sorry i know it's cheap but that
clip is just so perfect
because she completely makes up nonsense
he accepts the nonsense that god
got by producers and directors i've got
two guys in this room
they do better fact checking god bless
you guys and you know what you both can
have chipotle for lunch today
um bloomberg spent 500 million
on the campaign that's what they were
saying there's 327 million americans
so i'm just math in my head it's
basically like i don't know you give
everybody a dollar fifty not a million
dollars each and they let that run
and nobody corrected it
msnbc they've leaned so far forward they
actually fell into the bottomless pit
there you go